within supply-chain world the
uncertainties are becoming higher and
higher due to potential risks changes in
trades as well as the changing
technologies and the uncertainties
provide opportunities this program is
not about just how to do procurement
logistics but we try to link how product
development design thinking customer
service general management's are all
integrated because this is the new way
innovation is the centerpiece of our
focus you need to innovate the way you
work where you locate your factories how
do you do outsourcing offshoring
reshoring self-driving cars robots 3d
printing you can recreate a new form of
a supply chain this program gives you a
complete supply chain view all the way
from defining the strategy to your
execution so it gives you the full
visibility on how you can improve your
supply chain supply chain today has
evolved into becoming a weapon for
attack it is a value creating strategy
to gain market share in new markets
increase revenues to improve margins we
were given the tools to meet the
challenges that we're facing today the
business cases are absolutely fantastic
you need to strengthen your partners you
need to strengthen your supply bases you
need to strengthen your customer
relationships so that it's holistic
involving every member of the supply
chain
I can only remain in business if I bring
value to my customers because it's all
about value if I go to my customers I'm
able to show them what I am doing
differently a good football team muscle
good defense and also good offense
and we are helping our executives to
build a foundation of defense but also
have very strong offense as well I'm
very very impressed by the passion of
the people that are teaching these
classes I would recommend this course to
anybody who wants to make the supply
chain more strategic
we want our target executives to think
be willing to leverage innovations it's
a cause that's out definitely recommend
to others I believe that to be the the
best you have to learn from the best
I truly believe that this is the best
supply chain programs in the world
[Music]